buon pomeriggio
siamo nel 1979 e quel bambino aveva in
mano quello che ai tempi era il google i
15 chi conosce 15 per l'altra di mano
era il google di quei tempi la io avevo
5 anni e probabilmente la smorfia era
per le scarpe che mi faceva indossare
mia mamma
posso immaginare e se probabilmente
fossi nato in quest'epoca questa foto
sarebbe probabilmente è stata questa con
uno smartphone in mano e la tendenza
vedete anche a condividere le
informazioni in effetti in questi in
questi anni non c'è non c'è stato un
cambiamento ma c'è stata una vera e
propria rivoluzione che ha avuto un
impatto sia da un punto di vista sociale
da un punto di vista anche dell'impresa
è infatti è difficile quasi impossibile
trovare una persona oggi non so di
fronte all'uscita di un tram di un treno
senza uno smartphone in mano è quasi
impossibile e infatti la tecnologia ha
avuto un impatto sulla nostra vita già a
partire dalle nuove generazioni che
vediamo due generazioni a confronto
l'aquilone il self in stick e e gli
effetti di questa tecnologia si vedono
anche in spiaggia ad esempio attraverso
l'abbronzatura
quindi lo si vede anche in spiaggia a
volte magari per per fare una cena per
avere un po di di attenzione bisogna
fare delle performance circensi e c'è
stato un ristorante che ha avuto una
bella idea di per scoraggiare l'uso dei
cellulari è affatto questa questa avuto
quest'idea mete di cui vostri cellulari
il primo quello usa paga il conto e ho
trovato su internet questa bella
vignetta vedete la mamma che dice padre
bambino di dismetterlo che gli mando un
messaggino perché a volte la tecnologia
che anche questo ovviamente questo
impatto della tecnologia nel sociale
cioè avuto ovviamente anche anche nei
mercati per tanti settori in tanti
mercati
negli ultimi dieci anni è successo
esattamente questo
dall avere tantissima domanda ad avere
più offerta rispetto alla domanda e ad
esempio potremmo fare tante esempio vi
ho portato due tre esempi il primo di
una delle mie più grandi passioni che la
musica ad esempio la prima rivoluzione
nel settore della musica ci fu nel 1979
lo ricordate il walkman fu una
rivoluzione la possibilità di poter
correre con un aggeggio di meno di mezzo
chilo e sono serviti 21 anni per fare in
modo di poter avere oltre 100 brani in
una piccola per netina usb da poter
mettere magari macchina piuttosto del
computer ma già l'anno successivo
c'è stata una grande rivoluzione l'ipod
solo tre anni dopo c'è stata la
possibilità di poter avere tutti i video
tutta la musica gratuitamente con anche
la possibilità di essere protagonista e
tre anni dopo è arrivata all epoca di
spotify chi oggi ascolta la musica con
spotify della strade mano ecco qua così
come nella musica così anche pensato e
nei film nel 1985 ci fu questo grande
imprenditore david koch che inventò
blockbuster ve lo ricordate era un'idea
geniale il cinema a casa tua
uscivi prendevi la pizza è bene di un
bellissimo film a casa potevi mettere
pausa e vederti un bellissimo film ma
poi cosa è successo che è arrivato
itunes poi è arrivato amazon e questa
invenzione pian piano andata sempre di
più a a scemare
fin quando poi è arrivato a sky e sky
permette di poter vedere su un ipad
magari mettere stop attraverso sky go e
nel 2013
blockbuster ha portato i libri in
tribunale oggi siamo un'altra epoca che
è quella di netflix
beh non ne parliamo chi è nella
categoria degli anta per alzata di mano
lo so che una domanda scomoda ecco chi è
nella categoria degli anta sa che questo
non era un telefono cellulare
questo era il telefono cellulare perché
c'era comunque nec c'era il nec p7 c'era
comunque nokia ma questo è il telefono
cellulare ma quando poi nel
2007 arrivò questo signore e creò il suo
prima e sul primo iphone
esattamente quattro anni dopo il 15
agosto del 2011
la google compra motorola
quindi questo perché probabilmente nel
business vale la stessa teoria di questo
naturalista czarda wind che diceva non è
il più figo il più bravo il più grande
che farà la differenza ma è colui che sa
gestire il il cambiamento è infatti la
parola più comune che va più di moda in
questi anni è la parola crescità giusto
sì perché la crisi la crisi più
importante è la crisi delle idee e la
crisi dell'innovazione la crisi dei
business model perché chi invece in
questi anni ha saputo ribaltare i
business model ha saputo portare
innovazione idee nelle proprie imprese
in questi anni avuto una grande crescita
e facevo questo ragionamento proprio
recentemente erano sul treno italo
andavo a milano e ho fatto un acquisto
su aly baba è una volta sceso a milano
stazione centrale aveva un'auto huber
che mi veniva a prendere per portarmi in
un appartamento bellissimo in centro
affittato con a airbnb e pensavo questo
due le considerazioni alibaba oggi il
più grande sito di ecommerce al mondo
pensate 700mila superato i 700 milioni
di utenti fattura più di ebay amazon
insieme ma non a un magazzino un bel più
grande agendo al mondo di taxi ma non
una macchina a airbnb il più grande sito
di affitti al mondo ma non un
appartamento addirittura secondo il wall
street journal viene quotata la sua
valutazione di 24 miliardi di dollari ma
per avere un'idea un riferimento il
gruppo merito che gestisce 4 mila
alberghi viene valutata 21 miliardi e la
seconda riflessione è che queste due
aziende opera il bienne be dieci anni fa
non esistevano
ecco allora il concetto di voti formi o
ti fermi perché il cambiamento passa
innanzitutto attraverso la formazione
cioè la formazione è il ponte tra la tua
situazione attuale e la tua situazione
desiderata ma il cambiamento non è un
evento
il cambiamento è un processo che parte
innanzitutto da un modo di pensare e poi
di conseguenza di un modo di agire di
conseguenza porta dei risultati
io sono un imprenditore opera nel
settore della formazione manageriale e o
come dire un opportunità la fortuna di
potermi confrontare con le menti più
brillanti del pianeta i più grandi e
importanti spiegare tutto il mondo e
quindi di vedere un po le imprese da un
osservatorio privilegiato e soprattutto
quello che cerco di fare di utilizzare
quei principi che vengono espresse in
aula cioè di mettere in pratica io per
primo con i miei collaboratori
queste filosofie quindi vorrei
condividere oggi con voi 55 punti 5
filosofie che noi utilizziamo che fanno
parte un po del nostro main set
aziendale che tutti i giorni cerchiamo
di vivere all'interno della nostra
impresa con l'obiettivo magari di uscire
di qua oggi pomeriggio e non solo magari
portarvi via qualche qualche spunto
qualche risposta ma perché non portarli
via qualche domanda nuova da fare la
prima filosofia che noi viviamo è questa
cercare di disabituarsi velocemente cioè
cercare di in qualche modo aumentare il
processo di apprendimento
purtroppo siamo molto ancorati alle
vecchie abitudini
questa è una persona che passa per la
prima volta da da una macchina da
scrivere a un computer
facciamo fatica a ad abbracciare il
nuovo siamo sempre a baciare legati in
qualche modo i vecchi schemi
ad esempio se tu inizia a lavorare sul
mac è molto più facile iniziare a
lavorare da un mac senza aver mai
lavorato un computer piuttosto che
passare da un pc e poi andare ma è che
siete d'accordo perché perché nel
secondo caso devi prima disimparare e
poi devi imparare
e oggi rispetto a ieri questo è quello
che ci viene chiesto del mercato
disimparare di imparare velocemente
costantemente e questo è così importante
perché perché altrimenti ti ritrovi a
risolvere in qualche modo problemi nuovi
utilizzando strumenti vecchi
ecco perché così importante disabituarsi
velocemente al cambiamento e quello che
cerchiamo di fare ad esempio nella
nostra azienda è quello in qualche modo
di crearci un piccolo spazio nella
vostra mente come fossero un piccolo
reparto di ricerca e sviluppo nella
nostra mente e cerchiamo ad esempio ogni
volta che facciamo un evento quindi
riceviamo un sacco di complimenti
complimenti complimenti con noi
cerchiamo di fare una riunione l'abbiamo
iniziata
tyson meeting e questa riunione la
organizziamo e con tutto il gruppo
presente con tre domande
la prima domanda ognuno arriva a questa
riunione cercando di portare che cosa ha
funzionato di più in quell'evento perché
perché ovviamente lavoro la volta
successiva si può anche migliorare il
punto numero 2 cercare di capire che
cosa non ha funzionato ma non per
giudicare l'errore che cosa non ha
funzionato per cercare di capire qual è
la dinamica che ha scatenato
quell'errore una delle mie filosofie è
che un errore un errore
due errori dello stesso tipo sono un
modo di pensare quindi premiare la
filosofia dell'errore purché gli errori
siano sempre nuovi e il terzo punto
spazio alle idee i bar e quindi questa
questo tipo di schema che noi facciamo
ogni evento ci porta piano piano ad
alzare l'asticella della qualità
percepita chiaramente di tutti i nostri
comparti e se avete anche un gruppo di
collaboratori uno spunto velo può
fornire anche quello che io feci quando
aprì l'azienda avevo solamente un
collaboratore e mezzo ma per far capire
la mia filosofia mesi questo fogliettino
di fronte alla porta entrare solo con
soluzioni quindi cercare di creare una
cultura d'impresa dettata è basata sul
problem solving
non vengo da un programmino risolti o un
problema me lo risolvo vengo da te e lo
confrontiamo insieme questo è il primo
punto la prima filosofia la seconda è
questa un po come dicevo un po sono
contro intuitiva mette in discussione le
tue certezze perché le cose in funzione
di come le vediamo ci tornano quindi le
cose sono giuste o sbagliate in funzione
dal punto di vista in cui noi li vediamo
è ciò che ti sembra oggi giusto magari
lo rivedi domani e ti sembra
completamente sbagliato per mai successo
di rivedervi in una foto di vent'anni
prima
la prima sensazione che hai quando vedi
una foto di tanti anni fa ma come si
vestiva quel pirla li karité male ti
sembrava giusto poi a distanza di tempo
lo rivedi e le cose cambiano molto
spesso questo accade con le nostre idee
perché così importante premiare questa
cultura del cambiare idea
50 anni fa probabilmente cambiava idea
continuamente ma non era percepito come
un leader
anzi l'uomo che non cambiava idea
probabilmente era un autoritario
oggi se non ha le capacità di cambiare
velocemente oggi pa nel baratro
immediatamente e per le guide così
importante perché l'essere umano ha un
bisogno ossessivo di essere ed apparire
coerente con le decisioni che abbiamo
già preso e quindi il momento in cui tu
prendi un idea su un prodotto su una
promozione qualunque sia la l'idea che
ha in mente in quel momento scattano
delle pressioni dettate dal fatto che tu
vuoi per forza di cose rimanere coerente
con quell'idea e farai di tutto per
giustificarla anche se quell idea
sbagliata
allora noi che cosa abbiamo fatto ogni
volta che organizziamo del rey storming
quindi delle riunioni per cambiare ciò
che le cose accadono
ci sono due regole la prima regola è che
le idee non sono di nessuno
quindi tocca il tuo momento porti la tua
idea sul tavolo ma la tua idea in quel
momento non la puoi più difendere le
idee non sono di nessuno
e la seconda il secondo la seconda
regola è che ti devi innamorare delle
idee di qualcun altro è contro intuitivo
ma quello che accade è che si cerca
accade che c'è una circolarità di idee
dove tutti si innamora non delle proprie
tema delle idee degli altri
quindi si diventa in qualche modo più
oggettivi perché sei distaccato
emotivamente dalla tua idea e questo
cerca chiaramente porta un valore
aggiunto
il puc altrimenti che cosa succede che
noi vediamo ciò che cerchiamo quindi
quanto hai un'idea in testa non vedi più
le cose per come sono ma vedi le cose
per come siamo la terza filosofia è di
utilizzare le emozioni a nostro favore
c'è molta meno emozionalità nella nostra
mente di quando quando prendiamo le
decisioni di quello che pensiamo ad
esempio vi chiedo di leggere questa
frase rete arriva un po alla volta e vi
chiedo di leggere a voce alta
quest'altra fase al mio 3 1 2 3 1 2 3
buy
il momento la finale
ora capite che follia perché non c'è
scritto quello che voi avete detto se vi
concentrate su una singola parola vedete
che è completamente diverso quindi
vedete che ci sono dei meccanismi che
sfuggono la nostra razionalità e quindi
la maggior parte delle decisioni che
prendiamo le prendiamo attraverso una
dose imponente importante di emozioni
che cosa vuol dire quando che ci si
mette a dieta di solito quando magari ti
guardi allo specchio assomiglia ad homer
simpson difficilmente ti metti in dieta
quando le cose funzionano giusto
pensiamo un altro esempio quand'è che si
smette di fumare razionalmente te lo
scrivono che in realtà è il fumo fa male
ma di solito se vuoi fare un'indagine
con le persone che conoscete che hanno
smesso di fumare hanno smesso di fumare
all'improvviso quando hanno preso in
qualche modo una paura ho avuto
un'emozionalità che gli hanno permesso
di fare un'azione quindi qualche modo
attraverso la decisione
l'antifurto di solito quando che si
mette dopo che sono passati lario che
sono passati magari in quelli del tuo
del tuo vicino quindi l'informazione ce
l'hai
la razionalità ti permette di saperle
queste informazioni ma non è
l'informazione che ti fa prendere una
decisione che poi ti fa generare un
azione
anzi hai bisogno di un emozione questo
si lega al quanto che è questo cambia
quando tutto funziona perché se è vero
che sono le emozioni e quando le cose
non vanno a farti cambiare il meno è che
purtroppo a volte troppo tardi se cambi
quando ti arriva quel emozionalità
allora bisogna sviluppare un altro tipo
di approccio e cioè cambiare quando le
cose funzionano altrimenti quando sei
nella quotidianità cerchi di andare un
po nella tua zona di comfort e invece è
proprio lì quando le cose funzionano che
non deve dare niente per scontato e
cercare di cambiare di cambiare anche
quando le cose funzionano e molto spesso
questo accade nello sport per che
squadra che vince si cambia perché le
dinamiche psicologiche motivazionali che
ti hanno portato a vincere non è detto
che siano le stesse che ti portano a
rivincere il quinto punto
lei è una sinti montgomery una docente
di arpa che dice bisogna accettare le
cose che non si possono cambiare avere
il coraggio di cambiare le cose che si
possono cambiare e la saggezza per
capire la differenza è il quinto punto
anche questo non lo si trova sul libro
di economia
prima il cuore poi numeri io ho bisogno
di innamorarmi di un progetto ha bisogno
jack che mi faccia battere il cuore che
mi entusiasmi alla follia e una volta
che ce lo faccio le capriole per fare un
business plan e far tornare un conto
economico vincente perché se ciò che fai
è così lontano da ciò che sei
al lavoro ma io penso che nel business
debba anche essere la felicità ci debba
anche essere quella voglia che il lunedì
mattina quando va in ufficio 6 motivato
e per fare in modo da c'è bisogno che
ciò che fai si avvicini il più possibile
a ciò che sei
visto che in questo talk abbiamo più
volte utilizzato la parola rivoluzione
probabilmente la soluzione ce la offre
la parola stessa rivoluzione che in
inglese nel rivolution ha proprio questo
termine love
quindi il mio ultimo suggerimento è
quello di fare le vostre rivoluzioni
partendo sempre dal vostro
grazie